hey everyone this is Kevin from the
chesswebsite.com and today we're going
to be going over the Ryder Gambit which
is a very aggressive line in the
blackmar dimmer Gambit which starts out
with D4 D5 and then E4 gameting a Pawn
on e4
and then playing Knight to C3
the main line continues with Knight F6
simple development move also protects
the pawn on e4
then white plays F3 and after e takes
then Knight takes F3 this is what you
normally see in the black mardemer
preparing for the light Square Bishop
involve into the game if white wants to
Castle on the king side very similar to
The King's Gambit where that Rook is on
at the f-file uh just putting a lot of
pressure on the F7 Square in the king
side for black but
if white doesn't want to play Knight F3
and protect the pawn on D4 they have
another option and that is the rider
game but playing Queen takes on F3 and
you can see it's a Gambit on top of a
game but white already gave up a pawn in
material early on but now they're also
giving up this additional Pawn if black
wants to take it because because the
knight's not on F3 White's not
protecting the pawn on D4 now black does
not have to take it there's a few
options we'll look at a few of them one
I think is pretty common is going to
just be A6 this stops the move Bishop to
B5 which is pretty common from whites
you could also just see Knight to C6
adding another Central minor piece to
the board I think this makes a lot of
sense and then lastly we will look at if
the queen just takes on D4 this will be
the most common that you'll see we do
want to give you some options in case
they don't play the main line so let's
go ahead and first look at A6 as the
first option for black
now from here we're just going to push
forward with D5 and there's a couple
reasons for that one is we want to stop
the immediate threat that black has and
that is to play Knight C6 if you look at
where are they going to continue from
here
well they want to get their Knight
involved into the game it's never coming
to A6 anyway that's a terrible move but
they can't come to C6 now that's blocked
off can't come to D7 that's just
blocking off their light Square bishop
and their Queen and also the pawn on D5
what was on D4 was not protected by any
of White's pieces but on D5 it's now
protected by both the Knight and the
queen here and so black can't take that
white has too many Defenders here for
black to take and so black has to come
up with other options now we'll get two
here one is if they decide to go ahead
and push forward with their Pawn they
could also try to get other material
involved into the game they can't get
their dark Square Bishop involved into
the game yet so maybe they bring their
light Square Bishop involved this bishop
is protected by the knights on F6 but we
can just play Queen G3 and yes the queen
is no longer protecting the pawn but the
pawns actually still protected because
of an additional threat that we have and
that's just taking the bishop so if the
Knight takes oh we can just take the
Knight and if the queen takes we take
their bishop and now we have three minor
piece is to their two minor pieces and
we're going to be ahead in this game so
I don't think they would do that so they
have to come up with another option
we're attacking the bishop if they just
want to retreat their Bishop that's fine
with us if they decide to hold on to
their Bishop on G4 they might try
something like H5 okay well that holds
on to it here but then we can play
Bishop G5 I think this is better than
just playing H3 I like to get more
pieces involved into the attack the
reason Bishop to G5 is really good is
for two main reasons one is if they move
their Knight because it somewhat looks
like a a trap that hey they move it but
as soon as they do move it let's say
Knight takes on D5 we're now pinning
down this Pawn right here on E7 the pawn
really wants to move so the dark Square
Bishop involved to the game but the
queen would then fall so we can play H3
in this position
Force the black to do something more
than likely they take on C3 we take with
our Queen again if they don't play these
moves I think it's a mistake and kind of
show any optimal lines for both sides
now they have to play their Bishop so
maybe bishop to F5 but then we play Rook
D1 again this opens up for this Rook to
really control this D file they still
can't move their Pawn on the e-file
because of our Bishop it's just a huge
pain for them to have to deal with now
if we come back instead of the Knight
taking on D5
What If instead uh they just decide to
play
or if we come back one move after Bishop
to G5 what if they come out and play H4
well they can't really because now we
can just take with our Bishop on uh H4
so that's another reason why I like
playing Bishop to G5 is because we stop
the threat of them coming down here we
also depending on where they go they
don't have to take the pawn on D5 we can
go and castle on the queen side if we
move this bishop away we can't run out
can't Castle through check but if they
decide to not move this we can always
play H3 at a later time that is even
more so weak in our King side but then
we can force the bishop away Castle on
the queen side and have a pretty strong
attack so that's how I would approach it
if they play Bishop 2 G4 early on next
option is if they push forward with E5
okay well in this position I think it's
just best to play on Passat now if
you're not familiar with ambassant just
know that this is an actual move you can
and play Pawn takes here on E6 yes it
looks pretty funky but it's a real move
you have one opportunity to play that
and uh then you can't do it again
in this particular situation now again
if they play two moves up then you can
play opposant and and take have another
video on that if you want to take a look
I think they're probably going to retake
with their Bishop get material involved
into the game if they don't I think
could be of a huge mistake like what are
they really going to take with their
Pawn weaken their King side have an
isolated Pawn on the e-file that would
be a catastrophe I think so Bishop takes
on E6 is the play but then you can see
as soon as they move that light Square
Bishop we have the queen on F3 part of
the reason you play the rider game it is
to have a very active Queen if you're
one of these players that likes to have
your queen active this is going to be a
good one for you because we can swing in
with Queen takes on
B7 Now The Rook is under attack they
really have to play Knight to D7 Knight
to C6 would just be a catastrophe
because when we could just easily take
it for free here so Knight to D7 really
the only option that they have here and
then we can Play Bishop F4 getting more
material involved into the game and now
the queen and the bishop are both eyeing
down the C7 square and black almost has
to play Rook to ba if they don't it
would be another huge mistake so trying
to show you what they should play or if
you're black what you should be playing
and if they don't you should be looking
for ways to capitalize on that because
White's next move is going to be
Queen takes on C7 and if they play
something else instead of this Rook to
B8 we can just take the pawn on A6 if we
wanted to we can take with our Bishop as
well on C7 so we have some options
depending on where black goes maybe they
take with their Queen we take their
Queen they come down on B2
here's where things get somewhat
interesting we need to play Bishop to D3
now if you look at it and say well why
don't we just take this Pawn on A6 well
Bishop takes on A6 is actually a big
mistake for white
the reason it's a mistake is because
black has the move Bishop B4 pinning
down our Knight to the king there's no
great Square we could always play Knight
E2 but then they could just take our
Pawn they're just gobbling up so much
material here in these Gambit type games
you want to have the aggression
we don't have that at all King to D1
probably best because we don't want them
to just take with their Bishop freely
and then after we take they take with
their Rook so King to the one says yeah
if you take here we're gonna go ahead
and take your uh Rook on C2 so they
could just take with their Rook we take
they take our Knights here
but it's still pretty awkward you can
see they're attacking a rook on a one
and this is just not a good setup for
white you can see how different it is
just because we thought we could easily
take that pawn on A6 if we come back
instead we play the better move of
Bishop D3 instead of taking the pawn now
if they come down and play Bishop to B4
we can still play the Knight to E2 but
they don't have a good take here they
can't just take the pawn on C2 as we
said before if they take the Knight on
C3 we can just take with our Knight so
it's well defended in this position
eventually we can get this Pawn on A6
but just not right away
so those were some variations if they
play A6 I think more common than A6
would be Knight to C6 and queen takes on
D4 so we'll go over those Knight to C6
we're going to be playing Bishop to B5
pinning down that Knight to the King
right here now they have a few options
it does sort of look like it's a trap
hey we just keep wanting you to take
that pawn on D4 and if they didn't take
it before maybe they take it now but
this would actually be a big mistake we
can take with their Bishop if they take
with their Pawn hey all of a sudden we
Fork their Rook they have no real way to
continue from this uh you can see that
if they you know Play Bishop to D7 this
would be catastrophe even if they play
Queen to D7 we could just take their
Rook these are all bad moves they could
play King to D1 then we just take their
Rook how do they really continue from
here so that would be a big mistake if
they take with their Queen on uh D4 part
of the reason I like playing this bishop
to B5 pins down this night they can't do
much also I always want to give my
opponent the opportunity to make a
mistake now if they play A6 very similar
in that this is a bad move because we
can still play Bishop takes on C6 if
they take with their Pawn we're coming
up here Queen takes C6 check now they do
have Bishop D7 yeah that's an option we
can just come back to C4 and I think
this is a pretty good setup for white
now if we come back what if instead of
playing A6 they'd play the preferred
move and that's just Bishop to t7 now we
can play Knight to E2 the reason we play
this is getting ready to Castle on the
king side similar to a king's Gambit
where you have the f file semi-open for
The Rook to just rain down you can do
that you can get your dark Square Bishop
bombs to the game this light score
Bishop on D7 is blocking the queen on d8
they have none of their other pawns have
moved at all so they will have to do
something if they want to get their dark
scribbish involve into the game so just
like any game but you want to have
something in the form of compensation
and so you have to be very very
aggressive if you play normal gamuts you
definitely want to be somewhat
aggressive in the rider game but because
you're potentially giving up two pawns
even though they have not taken the D4
Pawn for the extra material you still
need to be extremely aggressive in this
opening
the last version we are going to look at
is if they take with their Queen on D4 I
think this is going to be the most
common that you'll see we're gonna play
Bishop to E3 getting material volume to
the game attacking the queen forcing it
to move
they should be playing Queen to G4
remember they're now up two Pawns in
material and so if they can trade down
specifically the Queens
that's going to be very good for black
anytime you're up in material you want
to trade down because you get to the end
your opponent doesn't have a lot of
material and you have more material than
they do as long as there's a ton of
material on the board doesn't always
matter how much your opponent has as
long as you have the most material
involved into the action that's why you
want to be very very aggressive in these
type of games so you have some options I
like to bring the queen back to F2 in
this spot because I don't like trading
off the Queens if I'm gonna give up two
pawns I want to have my most valuable
pieces on the board don't want to trade
off that Queen so if you look at it and
say oh you can Castle on the queen side
yes you can but then they're just gonna
take with their Queen here yes we can
take with our Knight with some Tempo we
have more material that has developed
but it's still difficult especially
without that Queen to really get a
strong Advantage down to pawn so I like
to bring the queen to F2 not the easiest
situation for white I'll be honest if
you've played this before you're
definitely gonna have a tough sledding
if your opponent is pretty competent but
if you like to be aggressive the rider
Gambit definitely allows you to do that
so I think they would usually play E5
they need to open up expand the open uh
the the middle of the board get both of
their Bishops involved Castle so they
have some safety
if you're playing against a Gambit you
want to make sure that your King's not
exposed because your opponent's usually
going to be attacking that from here we
could play Knight to F3 getting more
material involved into the game we're
going to be looking to get our light
scribbish involve into the game attack
our opponent castle and get our Rooks
involved before our opponent can do
anything that is the main game plan
especially if they play Queen takes on
D4 down two Pawn you have to be even
more aggressive so that is an overview
of the rider Gambit one of the more
popular lines in the black part Deemer
Gambit but let me know what you guys
think about this opening if you've
played it before or if you have other
aggressive lines that you want me to do
a video on let me know that as well
thank you guys so much for watching I'll
see you in the next video